[musiikki soi]
[musiikkia]
- Eläinystävä tässä mui. Minä vaan ihmettelen, mitä varten näitä nurmikoita leikataan aina, kun ne vähän kivhihertää ja joku pieni kukkanen siellä työttää.
- Onnistaan näkyville niin ei kun leikkuri tulee, Jyre ja Taason. Ihan ruskena kaikki nurmikot, että enpä ole moneen vuoteen nähnyt edes perhosen perhosta meidän käpialla.
Etä antakaa nyt ihmeessä niitten nurmikoiden kasvaku. Ei toi ruskea ruohikko ole minkään näköinen. Ajatekaa vähän itse.
Tämän kerran Kansan Radio aloitettiin luontotunnelmissa. Kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle. Taasen totean tutusti eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Jaksossa on tarjolla esimerkiksi alkoholia, maitopurkin korkkeja ja siivouskysymyksiä. Tämän heinäkuisen matkan mielipiteiden joella on koonnut Koiviston Lauri.
Eräs soittaja kaipaa enemmän suomalaisia hoivakoteihin. Toinen kansalainen haluaisi kauppoihin lisää penkkejä. Ja kysytäänpä myös, miksi lapset ei voisi jäädä kesäksi kouluun. Nyt on aika eläinasian.
Koskaan ei ole kuullut semmoista kuinka paljon nii koirat saastuttaa. Ja sitten vielä saastuttamisesta pitää sanoa, että totukoitsijatko heittää natsoja, niin suurin osa vissii niistä valuu vesistöihin, että se siitä saastuttamisesta.
Hei, täälläpä mumma. No nythan vasta Konkelo tuli. Onkos näitten viinaa uskaavien uupereilla? Onko niillä poliisivartio? Eihän näitä uskalla päästä tonne. Niitähän kiristetään ettei ryöstetä ja tehään vaikka mitä. Tää on aivan järkyttävän laki, muttakaan no herra Jumala tämä äkkiä, että kaikki asiat sopketaan viimeisen päälle ja luullaan, että siistihti mukaan viedään ja kauniisti ihmiset ottaa vastaan. Tämä ei mene näin. Tää on semmoinen.
Tuli kyllä semmoinen selvitettävä asia, että tätä ei sitten taas tuomarit pohtii kymmenen vuotta oikeudesta. Tehtiinkö oikein vai väärin, kun joku ihminen tapetaan ja kiristetään? On kyllä kauhea juttu tämä. Voi olkaa.
En näe, tää on pelkkää juoppuutta ja pahuutta täynnä. Aina vaan mennään alemmas. Tää on kohta kun sodoma, että kyllä ne jumalanrangaistukset tulee vähemmälläkin. Entä tarvitsisi vetää ihan tahalla omaan niskaansa, että kansanedustajien pitäisi olla semmoinen moraali vahti täällä maassa, missä me asumme. Nyt kun ajatellaan, että jos on tuo musliminusko, siellä ei ole ketään, kuka siellä pystyy, jossakin ravintolassa voidaan olla turisteille antaa, lähde jotain juomistaan, mutta siellä ei ole yhtään viinaa eikä niitä.
oluttakaan ei saa olla. Siellä pidetään semmoinen huoli, että jos tänne Suomeen tulisi tämmöinen uskomus, niin tällähän olisi kamala juttu, kun kaikki viinakaupat pantaisiin kiinni.
Että pitäisi ajatella sitä, että nyt nämä kaikki suvivirret ja muut, ne on niin myrkkyä kans, että ei vaan saa mainita, että Jeesus pelastaa tai jotain vastata. Kyllä tämä viina ei kyllä pelasta, se vaan hukuttaa. Ne hukkuu viinaa, ihmiset.
Minä olen itsekin nauttinut, siis sulkesin nauttinut tästä viinasta ja meinasin paljautua yhtenä talvina. Silloin minä tein Jeesuksen kanssa sopimuksen, että jos minut otetaan tämä viinahimo pois, niin en mennä viinakauppaa jo siitä yli kolmekymmentä vuotta. Ei tippaakaan sen jälkeen. Että tämmöinen on minun kohtaloni ja minä suosittelen toisillekin, että ilo on viinaa parempi kuin sen kanssa. Sen kanssa se on tehyskentelyllä. Kiitos kovasti.
On päätetty, että kotikuljetus alkaa, että jos ihminen on selvä, sanottiin uutisissa niin, että voi tilata sinne alkoholia, mutta oven takana voi olla avaamassa oven vaikka lapsi, muistisairas vanhus tai kaatokännissä oleva henkilö.
Aivan tolkutonta touhua. Joskus pitää ihmisten saada olla vaan rauhoittua omiin oloihinsa. Ja kun ulkomailta tilataan alkoholit, niin sinne menee nekin verorahat. Sitääkö tässä haetaan? Ei muuta, mummeli.
On näköjään suosinut niitä viinamäärämiä, kun ei ole mitään meteliä pitäneet äänestä. Älkää ikinä äänestäkö turistillisdemokraateja. No niin onnettomia puoluetakoja ne mitä saa aikaan vaan istuvat suurella palkalla silviisi hei.
On kerta kaikkiaan käännetty multa nyt tuolta maan pohjalta tänne päällepuolelle ja mitä lie pantui sinne alapuolelle? Heippa.
Kuulit vastauksen sama tilanne. Eduskunnan alkoholipolitiikassa nyt ruvetaan viinaa kantamaan kotiin ja sillä kysytään, että eikö se ole haitallista se viina, joten ei ole. Ei viina on niin viisasta juomaa ja kansaa pidetään kumminkin tyhmänä. No miten tyhmä kansa voi olla viisas?
Kattoa kohti ja perheet kärsii eikä tarvitse maksaa eläkettä sen jälkeen. Aattelepa itse. Minä ajattelen nyt niin, että on aika vaihtaa alkoholimaitoon tai ainakin sen purkin korkkiin.
Perä täältä saastamalla ytimestä hei. Puhun esiin semmoisesta, kuka älypää on keksinyt mehu- ja maitotöökkeihin tämän korkkisisteen, niin kun tyhmässä alkoholipullossa minä ymmärrän sen, että se korkki pitää säilytä tällaisen, mutta kun melkein se on hankala, kun se korkki jää lepsottamaan, jos yhtäkään veiessä kaataan, niin kyllä eihän maitotöökkit, se on kiernistä varaa muuten. Siinä se muovi roskaa kun mäleikkaa, se kyllä aina poies sitten, kun niissä on se ylimääräinen muovi. Ja tämmöinen kukahan älypäin ihmiset.
Sen keksii sen korkkisysteem. - Niin kaipaatko sitä vanhaa, jossa se avattiin semmoinen kolmio? - No kyllä se nyt on kätevämpi. Minun mielestäni on ollut tölkkeihin, koska se on helppo pistää sisäkkään sitä tölkkejä silloin kun on kierritysin intoillinen suorastaan, niin vaikka kierrätään nyt töltit kaikkia, pystytään sisäkkään niitä yleensäkin. No aina ylimäärävä vaiva kun elikkä on se muovin siitä pohjassa. Ihan turhan viritys se maito tölkkeihin on ja merkytölkkeihin semmoinen. - Sanoin nyt vielä, että mikä sinä erityisesti ärsyttäen on? Se on tää kierrätysnäkök
Minkä takia maito- ja mehutölkkeiden tarvitsee olla semmoinen muovikorkki, kun se kulmasta kätevästi aukesi ja tullaan se maatonokkaki.
Se on pieni ärsytys, mutta se ärsyttää mua enankin, kun väkisin tulee joskus semmoisia eteemis- tämä ylimäärän kort turhanpäite.
- Eli tässä oli jossa palataisiin sinun mielestäsi vanhaan, niin se olisi hyvä.
- Niin, no maitotölkkeekin kyllä saa ilman sitä korkkiakin, mutta jotain mehutölkkeihin saa, mutta kunhan joskus tulee käsi, niin semmoinen missä on se korkki.
- No siis onhan se tälläkin ajan, että se on kustannuskysymys, tuommoisen tölkkien tehden muovitettajalliseen siivuun. Tuulisitte semmoinen kustannuksen kannalta mitään tekemistä järjen kanssa. Tämä tämä vähän ihmettelee.
- Kiitoksia tästä ihmettelystä ja hyvää sununtaon jatkoa.
- Kiitos, samoin, sinne päin. Hei!
(Telefon täällä on Kylähullu Pohjois-Pirkanmaalta päivää. Päivää, päivää. Minä ihmettelen, minä kummastelen. Jostain maitopurkkien horkin irtoamisesta.
Pidetään pähinää, mutta unohdetaan paljon tärkeämmät asiat. - Mikä on tärkeämpi asia kuin maitopurkin korkki? - Meidän vanhukset, meidän vammaiset ja muut vähäosaiset, ne jää aina varjo. Niillä ei ole minkään näköstä kansanliikettä, joka niistä pitäisi pärinää ja pitäisi pikkusen huolta.
- Kei kerro sitten, että mitä on mieleenpäällä? - Se on mieleenpäällä, että vanhuksia ei kannata jättää yksin asuntoonsa omaan onnensa nojaan. Sinne on niin moni kuukahtanut ja kuukausien perästä vasta kun lemu on tarpeeks voimakas, niin löydetään. Kukaan ei huolehdi. - Mikä olisi ratkaisu tähän? - No herra, Jumala sentää, käytä joskus kattokas. - No niin, yksinkertainen ratkaisu. - Todella yksin.
- Mutta jos ei ole omaisia, niin kuka sinne menee? - Niin, kuka menee? - Puhutaan paljon siitä niin, että kuinka vanhuksista pidetään huolta. Öh, öh, pidetään juu, pelkissä puheissa. Miten pidetään sairaista huolta pelkissä puheissa? Nykyisin yhä enemmän vanhustenhuollosta sairaanhoidosta vähennetään, vähennetään. Porukkaa vähennetään, työntekijöitä vähennetään, rahoitusta vähennetään.
No tehdään kaikki pois. Nää sairaat ei pysty itse valvomaan omia etujaan. - Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta ja oikea hyvää snuta jatkoa. - Voimme. - Aivan pian kuulemme monipuolisen kattauksen kommentteja viime ohjelmien aiheisiin. Niitä puheluita ennen luen vielä yhden WhatsApp-viestin tuohon äskeiseen maitopurkkiasiaan. Hei, ei missään nimessä maitopurkesta muovikorkkia pois. Se on valmis.
Eväspurkki töissä, retkillä ynnä muuta. Ei tarvitse kaadella pulloihin maitoja enää. Tosi näppärä nyt. Tämän WhatsApp-viesti meillä on lähettänyt Pasi sotkamosta. Meille Kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia tekstikommentteja että myös äänimuotoisia, jollaisia on mukana muuten tässä ohjelmassa useampikin. Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 044.
5 5 1 5 4 6 4. Nimimerkki Kuopio vähän isompi piisa mirottaa. Nytten tässä kun kuunneltiin tätä kansanradiota, niin tuli mietitty, että tosiaan minkä takia siellä keselomalla pitää niitä kaikkien kaverien maalle lähteä. Minä mietin, että minkä takia ennen kuin keseloma alkaa, niin ei voi tehdä kouluhommia, kun pitää olla lähössä kaikkialle ja koulut lopetetaan viikkoa ennen. Minkä takia lapset voi vaan jäädä kouluun? Kiitos.
Nyt sunnuntaina oli kyllä todella hyvä tämä rouva, joka puhuu näistä älypuhelimista ja neteistä ynnä muista. En minäkään laita koskaan enä älypuhelinta. Minä tulen kyllä toimeen ilman älypuhelintakin. Ja sitä paitsi siitähän on nykyään jo terveyshaittoja. Jatkuvasti uutiset siitä kertovat, mitä se aiheuttaa ihmiselle. Siinä oli kysymys, minkä takia oli sellainen. Yleensä.
Ilmanen kaavi, mihin ne menee. Tämä johtuu varsinaisesti siitä, että se rauhoittaa paikkaa. Kun siellä käy poliisi välillä, se on aika halpa vartiointi. Kiitos.
No Raikka Lappeenrannasta. Morjes! Morjes, morjes! Kuuntelin äsken teidän ohjelmaajat. Ennen soittaa, mutta nyt soitan. Nyt pitää kouvilia, jotka soittivat sinne ja toisella oli asiaa siitä pankkiasiasta. Pitää kaikenlaista juttua tehdä, jos se on tietokonetta. Ja niin poispäin.
Olen täysin samaa mieltä, jos heille saan jotenkin terveys. Varmaan kuuntelevat sitten ensi viikolla. Heille semmoinen terveys on täysin samaa mieltä. Ja sitten sille rouvalle terveiset, joka puhuu täistä mainoksista, että on englanninkielistä. Ja niin poispäin. Samaa mieltä just hänenkin kanssaan. Just tuolle rouvallekin joskus sanon, että tää on niin pattii, kun on englanninkielistä tekstiä ja englanninkielellä puhutaan niin, että näin on tää tilanne kyllä. Se on Lauri, ihan totta näin. Ihan samaa mieltä on, että tällaiset terveyset Lappeenrannasta lähettää.
Kiitokset näistä terveistä ja hyvää sunnunta jatkoa. Jivat sinullekaan, skliffat. Okei, moi.
Olemme nyt siinä vaiheessa ohjelmaa, että keskiöön pääsevät kotimaista päätöksentekoa ruotivat puhelut.
Minon kun olen miettinyt tässä tätä Suomen nykytilaa. Kun priorisoidaan sitä sun tätä, mutta nythän minonkin sen tajunnu, että ne priorisoi sitä.
Eipä se hoitoa. Se priorisointi on paljon tärkeämpää kuin mekään palvelu, mutta itäminen on kans miettinyt, että onko ne ihan juoppoja nuo kansanedustajat, kun niillä pitää viinaa kuskata kyvään kotiin. Siksähän ne tuota aiheaa, ettei tarvitse itse viinakauppaa mennä ettei kukaan näe. Heippa.
Ja taas täältä Jyväskylän liepäiltä iltapäivää. Tässä on taas kuultu näitä hallituksen välisiä kauniita keskusteluita, jotka ei johda mihinkään. Eiks nyt on vihdoin viimea aika pistää se yks puolue ulos? Ainakin ne pääpukarit sieltä, jotka säilyttelee kaikki systeemit. Ei kannattaisi enää odotella. Ei hyödytä mitään. Toisaalta ei tässä tuu mitään muutakaan tapahtumaan kuin riitoja vaan. Hyvää kesää. Moi.
Ja sanoa että ei niillä tuolla hallituksen porukalla ole varmaan kielivellistä palanut. Aina sieltä tulee jotakin. Ja minä ihmettelen tuota paperin määrää kun tekee kaikkia lakeja ja mittään niistä ei toteu ja työpaikkoja luota ja niitäkään ei tule. Että mennäänkö ne kaikki paperit hyllypaperiksi? Ja sitähän ennen vanhan käytettiin. Pantiin naskala kiinni. Mistähän tulee hyviä hyllypapereita?
Noista hallituksen papereista. Tuuselta päivää. Nythän olisi tuhannen talan paikka ministerille kun saisi uuden veron mikä olisi tuommoinen maanpuolustusveron. Kello suurimmat tulot ja omaisuudet. Niille isoimmat verot ja pieni tuloisimmille pien vain pieni vero. Tällä sais paikka tuo valtion taloutta. Ja jos vielä tulisi liikekannanpanoja sota.
Niin siis isoimmat tuloisimmat suuromistajat etulinjan puolustamaan kun eihän pienituloisilla ole mitään puolustettavaa. Näin olisi tasapuolisesti. Hyvää päivänjatkoa. Hei seuraavissakin puheluissa ollaan vielä vahvasti vallan salien vaiheilla. Ennen näitä Audiomuotoisia ajatuksia yksi Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähetty viesti. Siinä lukee näin. Pääministeri Petteri Orpo on rahoittanut oma toimistoa.
Toivottavasti kardin Helsinki Areenan rakentamista kolme kolmenkymmenäviidellä miljoonalla eurolla ja valtiovarainministeri Jön ja valtiovarainministeri Rin on oltava ollut tästä asiasta tietoinen. Asiasta ei tullut löytyä mitään jälkiä ja tätä soisi jonkun tahon tutkivan. Liekei jopa poliisi asia. Ja nyt kun yksi tällainen suhumurointi paljastui. Mitä muuta paljastuu jos lähdetään kunnolla kaivelemaan edellisen pääministerin.
Joska koritkin kaiveltiin ampalajukurttien takia, jospa nyt jokin media kiinnostuisi kaivelemaan tällaista asiaa, johon kuluu miljoonia ja taas miljoonia meidän veronmaksajien rahoja. Maria Turusta oli lähettänyt tämän tekstin Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Näistä kansanedustajista eihän ne eivät istu siellä istuntosavuudessa sadantuhannen markan euron vuosi yksi tienisteille plus avustajapalka päälleni. Nämä Orpo mainitsemat kansakunnan kaapin päällä olevat ovat taas menneet alaspäin aika paljon. Nyt pitäisi kyllä ihmisten kattoo ketä ne sinne oikein äänestävät. Ei tässä muuta. Moi!
ja Rytman ajatteli panostaa golfiin puoli miljoonaa, jotta kokoomuslaiset ja persut pääsivät golffaamaan ja siinä sivussa nämä muutamat muutkin hallituspuolueet. Ihan ajattelin, että ajatteliko Rytmankin sille, että sinne vaan sitten vammaiset, turvakotiporukka ja kaikki muutkin nii golffaamaan, kun kaikesta otetaan rahaa pois. Toki sinnehän ei mahdu enää, kun nehän on päätettävät.
Jos on tarkoitettu perussuomalaisille ja kokoomuslaisillenne golfpaikat, kovin pienet tilit, niin täytyy ponsata golffia. Sinne vaan veteraalit golffaamaan. Häpeällistä ja Rytman pois ja äkkiä häpeäpilkkuja. Tällaista ei Suomi suvaitse emmekä halua tänne fasismia, napsismia. Suomi ei ole sitä. Kiitos, hei!
vaan siellä soitteilla. Ihmettelen vaan, että joko ollaan niin pitkällä tässä yhteiskunnassa, että sellaiset selvät väärinkäytökset, kun nyt oli juuri eduskunnan äänestä, tämmöiset niin sanottuja poliittisten järjestöjen tukirahoista, niin nekin painetaan jo villasella. Tässä joku vuosi tai vuosikymmeninkin taisi mennä jo siltä joku nuorisojärjestö kohni jotain rahoja, johon oli joku puolue kovasti sidottu siihenkin systeemiin. Ja nyt tuntuu taas siltä, että siellä on nyt kähmitty väärinkäytökset.
joka puolueesta kun ei kukaan uskalla vastustaa sitä korjauspäätöstä. Tää on niin kuin veronmaksajien ja kansalaisten kannalta vähän ihmeellinen asia, että kun pitäisi säästää ja sitten säästetään jostakin köyhilta ja muualta ja sitten noilta poliittisilta järjestöiltä ei sais ottaa mitään pois. Onhan tää niin kuin käsittämätön juttu, että me veronmaksajat joudutaan epäilemään tätä koko meidän järjestelmää, että tää on mätä. Niin kukahan tuonne sitten nää mielellään veroja
- No vihaiden kansalainen täällä. Elokuun joku puhui ja ehdotti, että kuinka kilometrikorvauksia pitäisi lisätä näille, jotka nyt vielä sattumoisten ovat töissä käyviä. Siis niitä töitä on eikä, ei millään eikä. Kansan talous on niin perselle. Ei voi. Mutansa olla, kun ministeri tarvii kulukorvauksia, niin noste tipahetti silleen 500 euroa kuukauden. Että tässä se niitten tasa- arvo. Ja sitten mummoja makuutetaan sägsyttä.
kun ei jakseta eikä laiteta resursseja, että tietäisiin edes ulos vähän. Eikö, annetaan maakas siellä vai omettua? Kyllä kaikki hoidetaan, sanoi Juuso. Mm, kyllä. Oimoi.
Voitteko te ihmiset käsitä, miten kuvottavia olette lävistysrojut naamassanne? Vanhuksen silmiin koskee teitä nähtyäni. Ne ovat sitä paitsi epähygieenisiä. Vanhus sanoo yök. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, johon lähettäjä ei ole laittanut mitään nimeä tai nimerkkiä. Kazardion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.yle.fi.
On tärkeätä olla verenpainemittari. Paineet pitäisi mitata aina aamulla heräämisen jälkeen, koska paine on alimillaan herätessä. Jos paine on alle satakaksikymmentä, siis yläpaine, niin olisi syytä nauttia jotain suolapitoista, esimerkiksi silliä leivän päällä tai suolakurkkua, sillä muuten on riski pyörtyä. On väärin, että paineiden suositusarvoja alennetaan lähes vuosittain ja kaiken takana on lääketeollisuus, joka tahallaan tekee verenpainelääkkeiden orjia.
Raima Rönkkö tältä Salosta. Hyvät kansanradion kuuntelijat. Minä olen sairastunut vakavaan lihastautiin nimeltään nekrotisoiva autohimmooni myöpatia, jonka aiheutti kolesterolilääke. Se aiheutti lihaksistoon toksisin myrkytystilaan. Lääke on myrkkyä. Mä oon taistellut nyt viisi vuotta lääkevahinkova kulutusyhtiön kanssa korvauksista. Mä olen parikymmentä tuhatta saanut sieltä korvauksia.
Joten sinne kannattaa tehdä korvausvaatimukset, mikäli teistä tuntuu että on jompikumpi jaloista mennyt ja ette kunnolla pääse liikkumaan. Eipä tässä muuta. Kiitos. Hyvää jatkoa. Rituli. Olen yhdessä suomalaisessa hoivakorjassa ja kaikki on täällä ihan muuten ok, mutta suomalaisiin voisi olla enemmän ulkomaalaisten asti. Tulee aina vähän ongelmia.
Ymmärryksen kanssa. Miksei suomalaiset hae lähihoitajat hae töihin?
Ilo täällä voi. Olen iloinen koska saan apua sairauteeti. Olen Päivystyksessä ja täällä Päivystyksessä hoidaan minua kiitettävästi. Hei!
Mutta siinä ovat penkin lisäksi mukana Pyyhe ja Paranoid. Ennen tätä kolmikkoa on paikallaan muistuttaa että Kansardion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjan tai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaa Chydamen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisinä tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Toivottavuusehdotusta kaikkiin päivittäisiin kauppoihin penkkejä joilla voin levähtää niin heikko kuntoisemmat ja äidit pikkulastensa kanssa ostoksensa ohella. Ei riitä vaikka isommissa on kahvilakulmaus. Penkit olisivat tärkeitä jopa nuoremmille joilla on jokin toipumisvamma ja liikkuminen heikkoa sopii myös ehdotuksena pienempiin kauppoihinkin.
Sen, että kauppiaat ottaisivat asiakkaittensa toiveet huomioon, joka helpottaisi useiden kauppareissua. Iloista kesää toivotan. Kiitos.
Kotona tuollaiset vanhanaikaiset, vaikka ne ovat uudet, mutta vanhanaikaiset pyyhennaulakot. Tiedät sellaiset koukut? -Muoviset. -Muoviset, juuri näin. Niihin laitetaan sitten käsipyhettä, kasvopyhettä ja sitten on vielä astia pyyhkeille ja paikkaa ja muuta. Mutta minne ovat hävinneet nämä ripustin koukut? Siis niitä, mitkä ovat siinä pyyhkeessä?
Sellaiset lenkit, mistä ne laitetaan siihen koukkuun. Että siellä saattaa olla joku tämmöinen muovinauha, joka on ommeltu siihen pyyhkeeseen. Siitähän voi tietysti ripustaa, mutta ei enää olisi niin hyvännäköisiä pyyhkeitä ja menisi paljon kaupungin ostamatta jää, kun eihän meillä ole mitään sellaisia kuivatustankoja niin kuin jossain hotelleissa tai jossain tällaisessa, missä niitä kuivatetaan noita pyyhkeitä.
Eli viestisi pyyheen valmistajille on, että lenkit takaisin. Lenkit takaisin ehdottomasti. Käytti, kuka käyttää ja kuka ei käyttä, niin repiköt pois. Kiitoksia tästä viestistä ja oikein hyvää kesäpäivän jatkoa. Kiitos, sitä samaa sinulle ja kiitos ohjelmausta. Hei hei! No Ile etä-asias, hei tämmönen. Onko Black Sabatin Paranoiden? Ja siitä on tehty suomenkielinen versio.
Mutta minä en muista kuka ja mikä bändi sen esitti. Haluaisin kuulla ja tietää mikä sen esitti. Oli se kiitollinen, jos kuulisin sen. Tämmönen vanha, 75-vuotias pappa haluaa kuunnella vanhaa paranoidea suomenkielisenä versiona. Maa!
Ed. Kun vuoron saa yksi tuttu kansalainen Keski-Suomesta, Ilelle vastaan omalta kohdaltani, että itse olen ainakin kuullut maalaispoika Alatalon tyylikkään suomiversion paranoidista. Mutta sitähän ei kysytty, joten palaan ruotuun ja luen nyt yhden postikortin ennen sitä seuraavaa puhelua.
Yläpäässä olisi vaaka-asennossa akseli ja alapäässä tuhannen kilon paino, joka on pienessä liikkeessä. Mikä energiaa tarvitaan, kun tanko väännetään akselista ylös suoraan pystyyn kolmessa sekunnissa? Tankon painoa ei huomioida. Näin meiltä kysyy nimimerkki Raimo postikortissa. Kortin kuvassa on muuten iloisennäköinen laama. Kansanradion voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perintä.
Kortteista postiaosoitteeseen Kansanradio pl seitsemänkymmentäyhdeksän nolla nolla kaksikymmentäneljä Yleisradio. No niin mauno Voutilainen Joutilaina, Kelan eläkeläisenä tässä Jyväskylästä soittelen. Riitän saada tältä koneesta ääniä kuulumaa. No niinhän se lähtee sitä väi ja tuota. No niin minulla tässä nyt olisi semmoista.
Täällä on idea että kun tuolla jaahallissa katossa siellä katto huoneesta siellä jaahallin katossa niin siellä on niin kosketin soittajia jotka tuota niin pelin aikana niin tuota niin eläytyvät näihin pelin tilanteisiin ja he soittavat sieltä sitten erilaista musiikkia niin tuota niillä koskettimilla ja efekteillä. Niin minä tässä harjoittelen semmoiseen virkaan nyt että että näin ikkältä miltäs tämä mitenkäs tämä nyt lähtee niin kun.
Nyt on tuota musiikkia nautittu sen verran että on paikallaan kuunnella välillä runoutta. Sehän sopii siinäkin mielessä hyvin kun runon ja suven päivä on hyvin ajankohtainen näin heinäkuussa.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton ja muistuksena että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Juho eli avantakelu jo tässä Imatralta päivää. Miten sinä tulee tänne tänne tänne tänne. Se on hyvä se sanat ja sanominen on kovasti vaikeaa. Voi olla jos ruvetaan treenata menekin opita koetetaan treenata sinne. Hyvä sanomissa ja tekemissä ja kiitos kansanradiosta.
Lostas tämmönen pikku runo ympettiin. Pieni punainen tipparello oli helluntaina hellu minulla autona tipparello. Hellu ottaa aamun kajos. Sitten minun rellu hajos. Morsio istuu verran alla. Minä makaan rellun alla. Onneksi oli mukana rautalankaa. Nyt ei pakari enää tietä hankaa. Vihdoin rellun mut perille vie. Tämä oli onnen tie ennen kuin syksy koittaa. Meille hääkellot soittaa. Loppui rellun pärinä. Tää on.
Vielä on ainakin aikaa tehdä loppusiivous. Ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää. Koiviston Lauri kiittäjä kumartaa, kansa radio jälleen viikon päästä.
No huomentapäivää tässä Kaarina Helsingistä soittelee. Siivoustyön asiantuntijoille nyt tästä pari kysymystä. Kysymys numero yksi: Onko nykyaikaiset siivousmetodit niin, että laitoksessa siistiä mopatessaan lattiaa märällä tai kostealla mopilla kulkee niin, että moppi menee edellä ja sitten tämä siistiä kävelee sen mopatun kostean kautta märän puhdistetun lattiaan.
Ennen vanhaa kun minä olin sairaala apulaisena kesätyössä niin meille opetettiin, että aina pitää peruttaa, että ei astu sen märän päälle, jolloin siihen ei jää jälkiä. Ja kun tätä asiaa kysyin laitoksessa, niin minulle sanottiin, että ei kun meille on opetettu näin, että näin pitää tehdä. Mut okei selvä kaikki muuttuu. Eskosenin toinen kysymys koskee ikkunanpesua. Kuulin tällaista väitettä, että nykyaikaiset tandardit on niin, että enää ei saisi ikkunan pesemiä.
Käyttää sanomalehteä viimeisteltäessä sitä ikkunaa. Eli onko tämäkin nyt joku uusi metodi ja onko siitä nyt jotain vaaraa? Näinkin minulle väitettiin. Elikkä siistiä työn asiantuntijoita nyt tähän haluaisin kovasti vastauksia. Mastavaa kesää kaikille ja ollaan siistiä. Moikka!
Hei ohjelma on ohjelma eikä mikään potkukassi.
Kiitos, että te olette tehneet tämän esityksen. Tämä on tärkeää, että me olemme tehneet tämän keskustelun, että se on erittäin tärkeää, että me olemme tehneet sen, että se on erittäin tärkeää, että me olemme tehneet sen, että se on erittäin tärkeää, että me olemme tehneet sen.